um so today I'm really glad to be here
and I would like to talk to you about a
problem at the intersection of queuing
system and the multi-armed vendors so
this is actually an ongoing work uh we
have some interesting findings
um but we may have raised more questions
than answers so I'm really looking
forward to hear your thoughts in the
comments okay so this is a drawing to
work with the uh Ife and the uh Julian
both at both from qinghai University
okay uh so let's get started
um so we look at the king system in this
King system we have case servers and
each server has its own queue okay and
jobs arrive to the system over time
whenever a job arrives we need to assign
the job to one of the servers
immediately okay and so for example here
uh maybe we give this job to server one
and then once it goes there because
there's nothing in front of it against
into service immediately and the service
times the time it takes follows a
modeled as a random variable that
follows the exponential distribution
with readme 1. so on average it takes
one over me one time to finish it uh so
meanwhile it's called the service rate
because then server one serves jobs at
read me one okay and then similarly for
the other servers they have their own
service reads and we are interested in
this setting we are the services are
different okay so this is motivated by
uh like for example into this Computing
systems the servers are really
heterogeneous they may come from
different times and they are of like
very different configurations so they
have very different service risks or
like another example I like is like it
so because the servers are usually share
the servers are usually shared by
different applications so the capacity
available to this particular application
might be varying over time and might be
very different about different servers
okay so those Service rates are
different and then when we design the
policy for choosing a job assignment the
goal is to minimize the job DeLay So job
delay is the time from when the job
arrives to the system until it gets
completed okay so then you can probably
imagine that in this system if we want
the job assignment policy to work well
it will give certain preference to the
faster servers okay however those
service trees may now be known up front
like again like from this Dynamic
example like where the servers are
shared by different applications so you
may not know ahead of time like how many
uh how fast the servers are okay so then
how should we do the job assignment here
okay so we
um yeah so this is basically the
question we want to answer here and we
probably what we can do is we can send
jobs to different servers and then we
can observe how much how long does it
take for each job to get to get served
and then like we get random samples of
the service time so in that sense this
problem resembles the multi I'm
Advantage problem
um in certain aspects right so here when
we send the job to a server it's like
pulling an arm like if we view each
server as an arm okay however I want you
to point out uh that those like those
two problems are different because like
basically uh our system here our tuning
system I think there should be yeah here
uh averaging system here has today's the
Q length are the states of the system uh
so a particular a particular particular
implication of that is like the actions
here like where you send the new job to
uh is not exchangeable over time and um
this is a simple fact of a tuning system
but I just want to make it super clear
for example like I if we consider two
servers and this is the double rival
sequence if we send like the jobs server
one first and then server one and server
two server two so our action sequence is
one one two two and if we compare it to
the other case where we send to server
one and two and two and one we can see
that if we do the first thing the job B
here gets queued behind a so it takes
longer to finish so basically if we swap
the order of the actions we get
different completion time for B and also
for D so the total job delay would be
different okay so the action sequence is
not exchangeable and basically this is
uh because we have the Q land here okay
so that's why they are different
um
uh so uh but when we think about this
problem we can still think about the
case where like if the services were
known then what should we do okay so for
this problem
um it helps to think about the arrival
rate which is like in multi-armed event
is if you know the uh mean reward of
different arms you probably just want to
put the optimal arm right but for this
problem uh we cannot just use the single
fast fastest server
um because like this arrival rate is the
number of double Rivals per unit of time
if it's higher than mu1 for example then
you will overload the first server and
although it's fast but there will be a
long queue here so uh a new when the new
job comes in it's not faster anymore
right so and in general like even when
Lambda is smaller than mu1 the optimal
policy probably is not to send all the
jobs to the fastest server okay okay so
um so that means like you good policy
here should take into account of both
the Q length and the service rate okay
so for this problem the optimal policy
is unknown so this of course we need to
Define what sensitive is optimal uh
traditionally usually you look at the uh
the job delay in steady state for that
metric we don't know the optimal policy
for finite time uh we don't really know
like and it's it's very it's not well
studied okay so we don't know the
optimal policy but
um because this abstraction is very
important many different uh many many
different policies have been proposed
and they either have certain as
asymptotic optimality guarantee or they
work well in in empirically okay so in
this in this work the approach we are
going to take is like this so we're
going to pick a good existing policy as
our Baseline policy okay and then what
we are going to to do is to mimic this
policy so we want to design an
assignment policy which we call Pet hat
to indicate that we don't know the
service risk and we are going to learn
the service risks on the Fly and then
like we want to just perform comparably
with respect to the space flight policy
and this is in terms of the total job
today okay okay so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to give you first to give
you two Baseline policies as examples
and then I'm going to generalize a
little bit okay so let's start with the
first example policy so this policy is
called the join the fastest the shortest
Cube it's very simple when the job comes
in you look at all the shortest skills
like the servers with the few with the
number of jobs and you may have multiple
ones with the equal number of jobs and
they are all the shortest accused right
if you encounter this case then you
break the tie favoring faster servers
okay so you select the server that is
the fastest okay so this policy has
asymptotic optimality guarantee for job
delay in certain scaling regime okay
okay so this is the trade this is the
policy we're going to mimic and the
other uh to our regret metric is defined
in the following way uh so the
superscript here Pi hat jfsu is going to
be uh the the algorithm we are going to
use that learns the services and the pi
jfsq is just a jfsq okay and then this Q
length here is the Q length at server I
at time T and we sum them up that will
be the total Q length in the system and
uh when we do the integral we have the
total delay of jobs that have arrived so
far so the reason that we have an
integral instead of a sum is just
because we work with the continuous time
it's not super different from a discrete
time models okay okay so we want to
measure this difference as our regret
and I'll come to the related work part
later but this regret to the uh notion
has been proposed the in the existing
paper by Sanjay and his co-authors okay
oh
so and in particular in this work we are
going to focus on the order of the
regret when the time goes to Infinity
we're not optimizing work we're not even
explicitly characterizing how it depends
on other parameters in the problem and
uh but I'm sure the dependence is not
tight I think so that's another that's
something we I will talk about a little
bit later okay
okay so
um so when we want to minimize regrets
usually we have this trade-off between
exploration the exploitation right so
I'm going to give you a intuitive
argument on why on why exploration is
necessary uh for this problem and but I
want you to tell me whether this
intuitive argument is correct or not
okay so let's think about a very simple
example here we have two servers this is
the first one is faster than the second
one and the level rate is super small
it's 0.01 times the slower server
service rate okay okay so what we are
going to do is we are going to do a so
what we call plugin gfsq it's very
simple which is the first we estimate
the service risk so basically in the
denominator this is the uh at the mean
the empirical mean of the service times
for jobs that have departed from server
I so we think one of that because we
want to estimate the the service rate
okay so we just do this and then we just
perform gfsq uh thinking of like
regarding the MU hacks as the true value
of the Muse okay so we'll just do this
um and then like let's think about the
system uh so uh suppose like suppose we
initialize things like initialize the
services to be super big so then the for
the first two double Rivals we give them
to server one server two so each of the
the two servers is going to get a one
sample of the service time but after
that like we have this estimation happen
to be in this case new one hat which
like new one is the fastest server but
the new one hat is smaller than a Mewtwo
hat is even smaller than the true value
of mu2 Okay so suppose we are in this
scenario it happens with certain
probability right and then make it a
revenue job usually sees the empty
system because our elaborate is super
small and then like most of the future
jobs will be assigned to server 2
because server 2 has like a server 2 has
a larger estimation here and if we keep
sending jobs to server 2 it's going to
improve it's going to approach the true
value of mu 2 but this is still above
the estimation for me one and then like
those jobs we should have given them to
server one because their their delay
will be one overview one which is
smaller and because the number of
arrivals is the linear in times we are
going to have a linear regret okay okay
so that's my argument is this correct
like has has everyone been following
like what is happening here
what do you think is it
is it correct like what is worth this
was my intuition for quite a long time
Jackie
oh really that like a job will arrive
even if there's already one yeah
that we'll have to explore
okay exactly so we should have invited
you earlier for a collaboration so this
was my intuition for a long time but
then we realized the simple fact like
once
um this argument is mostly wrong
although some parts look real uh so
because like when we give a job to This
Server too
um although Lambda is small but there's
a constant probability that there will
be another job that reps to the system
and in this game in this case because we
are following dfsq we are going to give
it to server one regardless of the
values of the SMS right so we're going
to explore anyway and then like over
time actually we can show that all the
servers get uh get enough number of
samples to distinguish uh to distinguish
their service trees and we're going to
get the order correct okay
exploration yeah yeah right I'm going to
I'm going to mention that like just in a
little bit right so yeah so this is like
a kind of free exploration given by the
algorithm and from here actually we are
going to we can show that
um yeah so yeah we can figure out the
order correctly and we will not suffer
from uh a linear regret and from here we
can actually prove that we can actually
bound the regret of this very simple
plugin algorithm so basically we can
show that at this time Point like
suppose the current time is T so by the
way this proof structure also is very
similar to what Sunday has proposed in
his previous paper so this is current
time key and at Time Square root of the
the two uh the two policies will agree
with each other but that I mean if they
were given the same realizations of Q
length they would do the same decision
okay but uh in real energy at this time
point because a lot of things happen
here so at this time Point their Q
length actors are not exactly the same
so well but we have a another entry
another very good property of gfsq so we
can show that like after this like those
two are basically the same policy okay
they're both the gfsq because they will
like always agree with each other and if
we can show that they both empty at
least once throughout this period with
the high probability the neck basically
that means they're going to be equal
with high probability by type key so
this is basically because we have this
so-called monotonicity of the of the
policy that means if we have two systems
both running the same policy and system
a starts with a higher Q length for
every queue then there exists a coupling
that maintains this dominance throughout
time okay so then later once one of
those two systems is zero is is the the
minimum Q lens you can imagine so it's
going to be dominating about the other
system and if the other system also hits
zero then they will be the same okay
okay and this can be uh proved this can
be proven using uh uh using uh the
heating time bounds that come from that
can be modified from the option of drift
conditions okay
so here so overall then putting them
together we actually have account
Okay so
uh yeah
that's the current time we fix the any
time key and and we want to figure out
what's the expected difference in the
two Q length vectors and then we will
integrate over time
uh but then you are assuming that by
square root of K they have agreed
right if T is large enough we can show
that by square root of T they they agree
with each other with high probability
like some probability like one minus one
over two years cute or something okay
okay
um yeah so I guess by this uh by this
point uh I think you
um you are you should be familiar with
the settings so that I'm going to uh
help you like put this this result into
the literature so we can position this
result okay so the high level message is
there has been increasing interest in
this problem at the intersection of
tuning and the learning and a lot of
results are for this model which is a
little bit different from our model so
in this model you have different types
of cues types of jobs and the jobs are
acute at their own own cues okay and the
servers are here and there each server
may have a different service risk for
different types of cues and our main
reference is this paper I've been
mentioning uh by uh Sanjay and his
Waters so there they can show that like
if you try to learn this this so-called
the simul rule you can also get a
constant regret and uh in particular
there's also a phenomenon of free
exploration that's super clear when you
have only one server here because then
like for one server you add the server
anyway needs to serve all the jobs and
regardless of the order of the service
you're going to serve all the jobs and
observe their service times so you get
this free exploration okay but the
algorithm there uh did use the force the
exploration okay and then they're having
like if you were here at the beginning
of the program uh you may remember uh
this talk given by Amy Ward on another
problem this is similar in the setting
but the jobs in the queue put the tendon
and then like there you want to learn
the CMU divided by feeder wolf it has
the abandoned abandonment rate and then
like there they they also use the force
exploration and get uh uh get different
regret bounds okay and then nature
there's also reason paper that uses max
weight policy as the Baseline but there
they they found that even making the
systems that stable is not
straightforward so they use the like a
discounted version of UCP to actually
get a policy that's guaranteed to be
stable okay and there are other relation
models for the interest time I'm going
to skip okay so for the
um I guess I'm running out of time but I
uh I'll need to oh there's a another
work by us before where we we try to use
the optimal probabilistic routing policy
as our Baseline which is a policy that
doesn't depend on the Queue length at
all okay so the rest of the talk is
going to be very brief so there's
another Baseline policy called The Never
Q shortest expected uh delay and uh so
in this policy it has two components one
is called the never queue that says if
there are MPT servers available you have
to go to the empty server and out of
those servers you you go to the fastest
one okay and then like there's another
add-on apart to deal with the case where
all the others uh there's no empty queue
in the system in this case you compute
an index value like this and you pick
the one that that has the smallest index
value so what this is showing here is
basically the expected delay if this new
job is going to join this particular
queue okay and this one was proposed
super early on in the paper like it's
just called the enqueue but we have the
NQ SED for clarity it has certain
guarantee so for this problem
uh like we can we just do the same thing
with data for gfsq like can we just do
the plugin version like that's a natural
question right so the enqueue part the
number two part actually guarantees that
we are going to have a lot of samples of
service times so we should be able to
estimate the service service risk to a
good accuracy okay
however does that guarantee that the
plugin version can agree with the
original version like a very quickly
so there's a little bit of complexity
here so for dfsq for all the queues not
on the diagonal you don't need the
estimation to make your decisions you
agree with the original one for things
under diagonal you only need to know the
order of the service raise right for
this particular policy it's a little bit
tricky because every decision here
depends on this value which has a
service rate in it those two thousands
here are the case where they are truly
equal okay so if we use a plug-in
version we're going to have a blurry
boundary uh and but that boundary will
shrink over time we are left with the
situation like this but for those two
red dots here
um for the it could go either way in the
plug-in version because your estimation
could could be like either above it or
below it and this was a this should be a
tie in the original system but in the
plugin system you don't see it okay so
uh then like that makes like a because
of this the coupling of the two
algorithm becomes complicated and we
actually have a simple fix for this I'm
going to go through this really quickly
so basically the idea is uh whenever you
want to pick the cube according to the
index value uh you should take the
smallest one but we are going to give it
a little bit of slack as long as the
queue has an index value that falls
within this band we are going to treat
it we are going to take it into the
selection set and within the selection
set with with choose the fastest server
okay so basically because
um the the if there there's a true tie
between those two cues both queues will
enter this selection set if there is no
tie between them then they are going to
be separated so we are going to as time
goes by we are going to be guaranteed
that the selection set only has skills
that are truly tied with each other okay
so then like here again again we have a
similar proof we can show that this has
a constant problem constant regret and
then like we actually make you very
little use of the structure of the index
value so we can generalize this to a
larger class of policies as long as the
index can make the system satisfy the
following two conditions one is this the
option of drift conditions that we need
for the healing time and the other one
is monotone okay so once we have those
two conditions actually we can show that
like this modified plugin version
it's not necessarily we just need like
we just need the Drifter to be like
connected okay yeah
as this
um is this uh definition I said if you
start if you run two systems following
the same policy if one system starts out
with the longer cues it's going to have
longer cubes all the way through okay
okay so yeah so actually we can we can
check some of the other policies in the
literature and they fit into this class
of policies okay and uh I'm going to
skip the summary because I think some
questions have like have like I said
like many questions have been bothering
me the first one is it seems that we
have shown that
um you don't need to do like explicit
exploration and then you get a constant
regret okay so then what is the role of
explicit exploration in the queuing and
the learning problem okay potentially
like uh although we get a constant
regret like I said the dependence on the
problem Dimension other dimensions might
be very bad like the number of servers
in the system so potentially we could
use like 4 the exploration or other
forms of exploration to speed up the
learning process to even like further
reduce the dependence on other problem
parameters okay so that's one thing I've
been thinking and another thing is like
we said we can learn uh this policy with
the constant regret without even
explicit exploration does that mean like
those policies are just easy to learn
like their learnability is high so how
should we quantify the learnability and
if they're how should they quantify that
and is there a trade-off between
learnability and the performance we
don't know the optimal policy maybe it's
really complicated that's really hard to
learn so how should we get rid of
between those okay and also like because
of the motivation we said that like the
system is heterogeneous because of this
Dynamic environment then what if the
system is truly Dynamic that the
services are even varying over time then
like how should we do this like this
this is a specially inspired by the work
by uh changing your hair
yeah and uh yeah
it assumes your benchmark
maybe you need exploration just to test
stability of The Benchmark or the
secrets right
I see but I'm saying suppose how do you
know if it is
like all of this is true conditioned on
The Benchmark class stabilizing the
system which is
in the work that you mean in the future
world or in the work we have African the
digital conditions so it is stable
right but I guess I'm here I'm wondering
maybe the role of exploration is to test
that
it
we would need to explore to check but
maybe you ask another question do we
know a way of testing stability
this is the ability of the learning of
The
Benchmark policy doing the weather is
stable without exploring without
exploring like with
like it's by observing the system
if you were to just assume the stable
Benchmark policy for which you know the
parameters would you have enough
exploration to notice
that like the state the system has
changed
like the underlying parameters
no okay we should take this off yeah
and uh there's another technical uh
question I've been thinking which is
like a other technique here really
relies on exactly the couple in the two
systems but whatever they just give it a
little bit like we cannot deal with that
in our truth right now but maybe we we
should be able to kind of like if the
limit only by a little bit like the tie
there perhaps they should still perform
similarly to each other okay okay so
yeah so that's the end of my talk I
think I'm using over time thank you so
much for staying here
so like I I have things that works all
other settings of this load balancing
problem so basically what they did is
like they have bosses and they trade
they they treat the process as black box
and like at each run they use one of the
policies that then they should they can
get like the best of both uh regrets and
like my question is like can you do the
same thing here and do you think this
kind of ideas will help you to solve
this setting okay I see so you you can
observe two policies and you're trying
to get the better one out of those two
and you don't need to actually figure
out the statistics of the system yeah
foreign